welcome to this video playing I don't
know what national master Zee eggs see
whatever a trade that mean I tried be
four for a change that opens the Syrian
and the way I'm playing at the moment it
probably does not matter what I do play
whether I know what opening or not i'm
playing a not very well ok we have a
Sicilian ravening on here therefore here
is going to play a five yes I think this
isn't a word line no he's 16 so this is
the type of position that was happening
many times in the 1980s and the early a
cup of kasparov matches in general
Kasparov played this line very often
with black yeah yeah I'm threatening a 5
positionally so he's some um covering
this trying to get something going on
the King side obviously
yeah the normal moopheus Bishop c8 I
mean maybe I'm not sure about what the
specific position but no this is how you
normally play it this is surprising can
you really do that amazing okay yeah of
course this is a bit open I understand
but still surprising that you could just
jettison the poem like that are why not
not so quickly and Queenie to looks
looks okay
yeah well came g4 is not ideal in this
open position but still that's even
annoying a queen trade and do that 94 is
just I could have rook chases was even
Bishop Bishop Jake's maybe by okay I
don't mind this is just simply okay
probably it's a good idea to exchange
this piece okay I need to be a bit
cautious about the PISA coordination
here 95 I can just skill Bishop f2
though this is okay knight on d4 is
supported by the pond and here i can
just play wiki one also i am it's made
on the edge so this f4 is not hanging
check should have to again or yeah maybe
this is also a setup I cannot play I
wanted to play King f2 yeah but he's got
Bishop H form enter King f1 there is 93
check so this was very very stupid okay
oh man i'm not making it very easy him
I'll just check a half an IG three but
of course I didn't plan this beforehand
now maybe it's not that that Tara would
certainly are necessary
My dear supply route d3 next
yeah unless he's got something great now
I'm starting to to gain some
coordination here JB three and keeping
the pawn when the King f3 is coming king
of three first yeah maybe ok so a 5-4
yeah probably trying to use a six in the
future as a weakness to attack it's
probably easier to attack then the beep
on I will play Bishop e3 and rock d 6 on
the other next moves okay to do this
anyway okay so look these six no this is
hanging
it's still good but I wonder if there is
some some more convincing way to play
I'm okay it should it should be good
what's up could have taken which would
would have been interesting okay but
then he has a rock on c3 it's not risen
so great
hmm ya b3 is also attacked
check
yet it should be winning somehow I'm not
completely sure yet how to how to do it
it's a black resilience you know he
wouldn't even lose on time but another
part should be it should be a little bit
too much what should he do I mean if he
why is a hard time here even to to stop
the a pawn if he placed the bishop bag I
go a 7 and he cannot really prevent that
they probably has to do this then
probably my night will help the the big
problem here in addition is he's playing
without the king my king is active here
supporting supporting the whole thing so
this should be a relatively relatively
easy win the night coming to c 6 for
example would be a totally decisive we
let let's say you play something like
that right then i can even take one two
three a minute it probably has to do
something let's say something like this
here yeah and now I'm this shouldn't
this should be quite easy rook moves and
then promote well it gets into a deadly
pin let's let's put it that way this is
this kind of stuff and wide wins easily
yeah this this type of position on the
opening is this well known but I'm
really not sure that that you should
should play d5 here maybe it's not so
terrible but I've never seen that this
early
right sure it should be some advantage
or what I don't think it can be a can be
a sufficient compensation okay thanks
for watching